[Applause]
we've known each other a long time
[Music]
you never had this much trouble
this
[Music]
hey honey need assistance
okay you have to hit every single bump
in the road run right through
zero up trucha you crazy nuts
yeah he's real pro at smacking dealers
around that's why building that well
function in our to kick demonex
[Music]
what no chitchat or monologue just
getting right to the point huh
not really a badass work is worth every
dime you know the cash first
[Music]
[Applause]
gasps go itself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome from Capcom producer Matt
Walker and director today okay it's uno
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
advaitha I wait for years for this thank
you so much
the MC is back
English English is hard math you day
of course it's been 10 years since Devil
May Cry 4 was released and fans have
been asking for a true sequel ever since
so this is our response loud and clear
that we hear you devil may cry and
Hideaki eat soon Oh our back
early on in the development devil may
cry five we set our sights on creating
something that was gonna have
world-class visuals so we've scanned
fully costume models for all of our main
characters and with the power of Xbox
one X we're able to render them as
realistically as possible
now while visuals are really important
the controls need to remain tight
responsive as well so we've gathered the
best minds at Capcom to ensure that we
can still deliver that amazing gameplay
that definitely cry is known for and we
think that we made something that feels
better than any action game we've ever
created hoorah hoorah see they they all
want law yeah yeah Samantha many achieve
are not jeans athletic we must stop hey
spice tomorrow this your score Hamas
Suzanne says that he is convinced that
this is the best game that he's ever
made because we made it for you our fans
and we hope you look forward to seeing
more
[Applause]